(guitar music)
- [Voiceover] Dead Kevin
- Alright guys all we
have is this weird potato
and a bunch of condiments.
- No no no, I don't think
you're understanding.
If we pay this bill we will
literally have negative dollar,
like what do you recommend?
- Ryan, Ryan!
Do you want your
work clothes in here?
- Yeah, whatever.
Now here's my question
why are you telling us
that our balance is outstanding?
- Hey guys!
- Hey Richard.
- Hey Richard, what's up?
- What, what are we gymnasts?
- Sorry
- (Knocks) What
does that even mean?
- Richard, we were just
gonna sit down for dinner.
- Ah it's cool, I just ate.
- It's not really a good
time right now Richard.
- What are you doing, bills?
- Yeah, okay I'm gonna have
a word with your manager.
- Mmm, seasoning.
(scoffs)
So this is literally all of
the clothes that we have.
I don't think we have
enough quarters for this.
- You guys doing laundry?
- Uhh, nah --
- Can I help?
- [Ahmed] No thanks.
- No it's cool I just got
a new dryer downs stairs,
I could help you guys
finish this laundry.
- [Ahmed] It's just
kinda weird, Richard.
- Weird?
- [Ahmed] Our
underwear is in there.
- A friend helping a friend,
when is that weird huh?
I'll get this done really
fast, I'll be right back.
Is that cool?
Thank you.
(sighs)
Guys, before you freak out,
I want each and every
one of you to know
how very sorry I am.
Obviously I didn't mean for
this to happen, you know.
It was an accident and you
gotta forgive me 'cause
that's what friends do!
- You're fucking crazy!
- We don't have money
to buy new clothes.
- Guys, let's be real.
We're pulling this off together.
You guys look
cool, you're great.
- This isn't cool.
- Ryan, please
don't be mad at me.
Honestly, I've never seen
your pecks more defined.
- Fucking son of a bitch!
(yelling)
You're a monster!
- Get out of here!
- You're a monster!
(yelling)
- You got it?
- Okay!
- You cool?
- Yes.
I got a job interview
in 20 minutes.
- You're gonna do great,
your hair looks good.
- [Ryan] Thank you.
- Ahmed, I'm sorry.
- Richard.
- Jack, come on man.
- Richard if you could just
pitch in help us buy like
a couple of shirts.
- I don't have any money
for your guys' clothes
I just got a new dryer.
- Look Richard,
I don't think you should come
around here anymore, you know?
- What?
I'm downstairs, I'm your
neighbor, I'm your friend.
Who's gonna help you
guys laundry or whatever.
- This is it, this was
it, this was the last --
- Fuck you!
- Ryan, i'm sorry!
You look good!
(door slams)
He's not gonna get a job
with an attitude like that.
(guitar music)
(knocks)
- Hey neighbors, tell us
about your crazy neighbors
in the comments
section and be sure
to subscribe to Dead
Kevin on YouTube.
(smooches)